uh-oh we got the minimum I didn't even
enter whoo lucky number what lucky
number 21 or 22 here's the breakdown
bullet Zone one warzone rated 23 players
currently average rating 2062 time is
the handicap 30-minute tournament level
52 enter tournament on here we go
sweetness I'm playing against sweetness
right here
who's this Walter Payton sweetness is
Walter Payton I don't know if you knew
that who's Walter Payton some might be
asking the Bears the Bears I'm playing
against the Bears okay let's get my
bishop top they move their piece again
they moved it from the center fishing
pool no way or is this back is this
still happening is this still a
possibility it might be oh I had Knight
here which was killer
there it is waiting move I had it
earlier quick kill back to tournament
first blood who drew first blood oh man
the tournament shake and now I have no
idea what I'm talking about but I guess
I got the first win let's go Oh cause
Cosman 2002 let's go I gotta Center more
fishing poles more fishing poles more
fishing poles I'm not finished
uh-oh I messed up or did I Bishop check
fishing I'm going fishing no I need bang
on to that guy if I want to get the
fishing in get out of there oh look at
that
okay let's go here that's an ugly spot
for my bishop but I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do it fishing pole
fishing pole 30 seconds they they're
sniffing out the fishing pole they don't
want to do it okay let's come here I
still I'm still gonna do it though if
they do that somehow it's probably good
okay
I'm insisting ah there we go we got some
play for my pond
oh they got that move though weasel
about night you know you want to get
right here and get my [ __ ] up
let's go here oh this is sneaky let's do
this guard this and that's my night here
soon they're gonna trade Queens they're
gonna trade Queens I don't have a lot of
time where did my time go get up here
king my king wants to be on he floor I
lied my king would like that square
better what's happening here open this
up break it down break it down break it
down here there we go now get the
central pawns going take take my pond
now check come here King nine point five
I'm on the rook hit did not hit the roof
Oh check they'll never suspect that they
did suspect that come back here run here
go here watch out for checks yes come
back here check check moves come back
here get the rope oh do four to six six
four two a bunch of two's here we go oh
this guy give me gave me a couple
beatings already gave me a couple of
beatings already at least two beatings
is he gonna give me a third that's the
what's the anti fishing pole right there
Oh
let's go fish let's go fish here before
coming up okay can I sneak in this here
night let's exchange nights oh let's do
this and then I could do this my bishop
is in a good spot at least take like
that
what am i doing oh let's play here
what's going on here though its guard
this pond and then push I'm gonna push
pipe on there we go this is this is good
maybe push this guy a guy really fast I
should have taken this guy what am i
doing
push Ron a pond run you can do it
flight square oh boy oh boy let's oh
what am i doing to have connected past
ponds that can't be good for me that
that cannot be good for me at all what
is that rip doing what am i doing I
should have taken fun I'm gonna have to
sack here okay around this bunch of
times
oh boy I gotta go with this there in
check and I get that rook at least
looking for mate after it Oh mate threat
still it's still a mate threat bait made
a cut 3 4 3 3 4 3 12 there's some big
dogs here though there's some big ones
Oh a lot of time left we're only 5
minutes in less than 25 tick tick tick
tick tick clock is ticking and they're
not pairing me up no pair it up let's go
here here we go Linna minute here we go
ah let's double those points everybody
wants to double the points it's what
it's all about double those points get
that Center in let's come here
I don't want Forex happening let's chop
them up chop them up let's get this in
right now right now let's go here watch
over with c3 c3 is happening let's get
my bishop here be six is happening
killer move d6 is happening d6 there's
Knight takes here my Knights unprotected
I got to come back pawn push I got to
come back again
let's hit the bishop get rid of it it's
the most powerful piece that Knight is
close to trapped he's close to trapped
oh let's do this man I shouldn't have
done that
okay the bishop has to give itself up
soon I think
and now it doesn't let's get rid of it
and Knight wants to go let's do this
first
oh let's take this why not the night
block that so Bishop here maybe to a6 if
they don't take let's chop it up go here
and let's do this next looking for what
no that wasn't the right idea
don't take my a pawn please okay good
man forks forks Oh check not check that
wasn't check I lied I lied on that one
that was not check my queen my queen
everything is okay everything is smooth
back to tournament quick win 2014 seven
six five a lot of time though a lot of
time a lot of time I'm getting some
relatively quick wins in somehow I'm
managing some quick wins some quick wins
are happening is that a waste of time
are they going to defend it
Oh more fishing go fish more fishing if
you're watching this and you uh and you
end up not feeling well at night you are
all just gonna be hearing me saying
fishing pole fishing pole you will not
be able to get that out of your head oh
it's gonna happen there we go we have
this again the same idea deflection h2
killer and you see it it's happening
more than once oh I could take the Queen
with check
I'm not going to though I want me oh wow
who would have thought who would have
thought that maybe not taking there was
best okay now it is actually cuz the
king could sneak away somehow but let's
do this let's do this and let's do this
and I'm gonna retreat my knight soon
okay let's let's trade just a little bit
how much time do I have I have enough
time let's do this flight square for my
ping right here is a decent one right
here's a decent one and trade some more
more trades rook let's just take care is
there mate
Bishop pin take the bishop take the pawn
how much time do they have let's just
take care they don't have any time back
to tournament thirty twenty bunch of
tens thirty twenty a bunch of tens okay
it can be set back at any moment here at
any moment are they going to UM push
there no they're not because there'd be
Queen a5 if I took that pun let's do
this
and now okay let's get this in so I
already played them a slower game like
this let's watch over it
there's Knight takes Knight in that
position I believe timely move to force
my queen to recapture instead of my
bishop
so castle ninety five we've been here
before I have some experience already
Knight here would have been better while
the knight was still on c6 so I could
pick up the minor piece let's get up
rook to d1 still capture in this
direction and what am i doing I need I
need to push that night around but I
can't I can't do that get on this file
stop them from getting their seventh
ranked work on this file that's the only
advantage I have here we go
let's take here first seventh rank this
is an issue Queen takes Knight here
Forks let's throw in a check now this
and then this check and then this and
then Bishop on that no I'm actually it's
a free piece oh okay oh I have
everything under control that was a
blunder on their part quick resigner
resigned 42 42 2015 don't tell me I'm
gonna run away with this no way no way
there's too many strong players I'm
gonna get beat up I can feel it I can
feel it less than 20 less than 20 here
we go here we go could we get three
fishing poles in a row now they're gone
for Smith more gambit or are they
oh I'm gonna hang on to this pond now
Knight takes Queen a5 that's I was
talking about earlier next up they might
be challenging with F floor I want to
take that into account so that's what my
Knights doing dark square bishop dark
square bishop dark square bishop beware
be very aware the dark square bishop
what is going on here I have that
covered my bishops covered what's going
on
am I missing something I'm not missing
anything
where am I where am I
Queen trade watch over this square
there's too many pieces that could go
there
Queen trade rook activity what am I
missing nothing missing anything
Oh mate - somehow Knight here is a
killer isn't it it's a killer I got the
Queen they messed up I was being sneaky
h7 grab a knight grab a bishop
grab the knight in the corner one day
resignation back the tournament what's
happening here 56 30 2018 low frequency
let's see if low frequency is gonna be
traveling at a high pace somebody knew
that was coming it took a while to come
out there okay Oh Oh going fishing more
fishing more fishing Oh
this right here is good it's gotta be
right they can't be too happy about
having that they can't be happy about
that night being in a pen and the Queen
being stuck there right so what do you
do you pile up on the pin piece that's
the idea let's do this
and then that's defended they're still
in a pin they're still in a pin land
they're still in pin land here oh that's
got to be a killer that's got to be a
killer Forks grab a rope grab a knight
give a check on h5 let's do this I'm up
a full rook now resignation no
resignation pile-up I'm the pin piece
open it up open it up here bishops off
Bishop takes take the rook
take the rook take this come here I
might end up in a pin not so fast I
could pre move this one Forks where
their Forks where's the king gonna go
trouble matin one to got it back to
tournament 72 72 twenty eight twenty
eight twenty eighteen sixteen Evan here
we go let's go
what is this setup that we have each
pawn attack can i really get that in h4
what do we got shut down that bishop
shut down the bishop can we have that
happen
how much time is left my clock isn't
ticking what's going on is there an
issue on their end shut that down tanks
get to III get to this square fishing
going fishing clean over if King up ok
now this light square is where the light
squares let's do this the night is still
in a pin queenside castle the knight is
out of a pin soon
or is it it stake here and then get my
queen force my queen to get there dark
squares let's take that dark square
bishop and then get my knight where I'm
on that pond I'm also on this let's get
my knight to d3 chasing your way to a
square it wanted to go to right Knight -
there may threat maybe this has got to
be a killer right where is it
let's get this rook over night to e3
night to e3 has to be strong 20 seconds
it's a fork oh oh let's grab this and
then this one is there a defense on that
pond getting on c4 next with check pile
up on this pond there's no defense is
there resignation 13 12 11 is this war
lag oh there could grab my knight
I missed that move whose move is it they
resigned back to tournament 90 40 35 30
26 less than 15 were halfway there efore
I shouldn't have done that my Nike get
pushed around okay
let's do this he's got this in and stop
the bishop from coming out although they
could have grabbed that pun that
probably would have been good so okay
let's come here Knight h5 could be real
strong Knight h5 could be really really
strong I'm gonna push this night away
and then do what next let's go here and
let's do what am i doing I moved I
didn't mean to move oh I didn't mean
that even there's Knight takes pawn here
ah I'm miss play that there's a fork at
least am I missing something I want to
take that light square Bishop let's get
this night out of here that Knight needs
to go and my rook wants to play to d6
okay there's um I'm on their rope they
missed that let's trade Bishop's I'm up
a full rook how much time is left check
let's come here they're gonna do a pawn
push I'm just gonna take it no mates
just play right here no mates Queen
trade coming up clean trade soon let's
play here still just watch all of
everything I'm just gonna double rooks
next double rooks play my king here or
maybe not no I don't want that file to
open up so I just need to be very
cautious of my king for a little bit and
everything should be quite all right
attack the Queen get my queen to c7
check clean trade next otherwise it's
made main back to tournament one ten
forty thirty four twenty eight twenty
six twenty six less than 14 13 and
change 13 three what do we got what do
we got what do we got okay can we go
three four three this has already
happened twice fishing poles
Oh LightSquared bishop though this is
the imbalance bishop on v7 let's back up
and get in d6 and then what oh they're
looking for me I'm defending and hitting
the knight and now I gain tempo with
this I'm okay with takes I want to try
and get something going with h5 let me
get h5 in soon I want to watch over this
square I could kick the night away any
second queenside castle clean side
castle and then f5 is the plan Knight
right here oh not so fast let's watch
over that pond and then Isis closed over
here f5 coming up
f5 let's do this first it might be
something with rook here got to get that
night out of there I just dropped a pun
let's take care first I want to take
that night and then play f5 take that
night and then play f5 make this work am
I getting this so they going to take my
bishop let's do that and I'm in a place
called trouble here hopefully this works
hopefully this works somehow they
shouldn't have done that should they
they're gonna give a rook check though
gotta watch over this this is not good
it's just not good right here I'm in
trouble I'm in trouble here what do I
have I don't have anything oh man I
don't have anything what am i doing what
am i doing here Bishop takes Bishop
takes is still there can I defend this
somehow time how's the time situation oh
I just dropped my rook anything but that
oh man anything but that can I get a
draw out of this how much time no it's
not happening oh if only I would have
kept my rook should I just be resigning
yeah I should have backed a tournament I
forfeited on time 108 oh that's a tough
one again Evan here we go
um let's try this what are we gonna have
okay that was a bad one to lose right
there if a five comes okay I got to
defend this get my knight on D to D five
is gonna be played soon
d five it is okay hopefully this holds
up is it gonna hold up let's get this in
here after watch over C for my knight is
secure here rook to d1 soon and I think
Knight c4 I want to stop that Bishop to
here next I have coverage on this square
take the knight maybe chase the night
away Knight here I should have done
Knight right there get it to d6 maybe
even take this pawn maybe even get g4 f5
in g4 f5 let's just try it
open things up take with my knight and
then I have this defended what do we
have what do we have here what do we
have let's get this over here take my
okay let's get on this right here and
take up my queen I have to watch over
this prime I want to play here and then
smash through somehow actually this has
to be pretty good I'm on the rook I'm on
the rook there on my bishop though
they're on my bishop I have a check oh
is this decent I could take the bishop
with check and then and then do what
let's give a check here check here takes
and then where is the winning move right
here where does the winning move is
their winning move anywhere do I have
any winning moves give check and then
give check here oh is my king fast
enough oh maybe they could play just
played behind the rook there I'm down
material why did I go for a queen trade
my King is gonna be fast enough get
behind it Queen King I don't have a
queen okay this is no good let's throw
on some checks more checks I'm helping
their King out by doing that why did I
do that ah that was just helping their
King out let's do this and then they're
gonna give a check I'm in trouble I
don't have any time no time
me they fell for me back to Turin oh man
that one is painful that one is painful
ouch oh I was beat in that final
position would have been a difficult
road ahead at the very least a difficult
difficult road ahead okay what am I
missing and skip this out bishop here
okay let's go here before it stings me
here and now let's come here fishing
pull land take my bishop okay support my
center that's why I'm taking like this I
could play d5 not so fast though so I
gotta take with my pond and that's not
how they take so let's get this in I'm
on their pond and oh man
okay let's let's do this and then take
here somehow let's take and then take is
there like um what do we got here the
night's gonna be problem isn't it it's
gonna take there got to give a check and
then watch over this man it's not
working out it's not working out here
I'm gonna end up in a fork very soon
this is not good not good at all let's
get over here
do something over here just get that
tricky Knight out of there
oh there's rook check rook check would
have been very good mate look for me
are they gonna forget about that can I
get one of their pawns okay let's come
here and then get that beep on the beep
on is the one that I want most there now
let me get it let me take here I'm in
trouble I'm in trouble I'm in trouble I
got to throw in a lot of checks here can
my King cross I want my king to cross
come on King Oh might be close to a mate
maybe no they're doing that I have um I
have something though I think I have
something push here
Oh what do we got here push there might
be some tricks that I have uh oh what's
this check come back over here get my
king oh that's the wrong spot to go with
my rook that's where I meant to go what
do we got something I got maybe 0.8
matin one hon I'm gonna be in check I'm
down on time I didn't have any time they
had a lot of time 126
excuse me 126 what am I at Oh another
loss that's a tough one ah man okay
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's get castled get my rook to e1 and
then or no let's get this in so this is
a transposition I've been here before
this stream a few times already this one
a couple rook after d1 let's watch over
c4 Knight to d5 rook after d1 Knight to
d5 next Queens trade I might want to
throw in no no no no no no let's not do
that
I gotta go like this my rook is
unprotected on see what a pain I want to
get in c5 can I make that happen let's
get this night out of there he's bugging
me
he's a bugger Knight g4 I have to take
it he4 I have to take it and now here we
go here we go here we go
this has to be good get out of there
Bishop it's gonna kick my brook around
okay this is gotta get rid of that dark
square Bishop get rid of the dark square
Bishop get out of there
g4 next rook b2 I want a guard against
the seventh rank or do I let's hit this
pawn and then hit it again I'll punish
just crashed through Forks something
open it up over here my knight is dead
why did I give up my knight I have to
break this open take here I want to
secure this pond it's very valuable very
very valuable 31 seconds
they can't go too far away stop that
pond from getting any further no more
play for that pun I have more space for
my king
let's go King let's go King okay let's
get back here guard my pond play my pawn
to a4 and then get my king over
let's go King they don't have any time
no time no time no time zigzag my king
back to tournament 146 121 102 less than
four minutes that guy could still catch
me right here less than four maybe two
more games if I get one more in and
might be close to sealed maybe maybe
maybe maybe I want that confetti
I want that confetti and a first-place
the confetti is not enough I want the
confetti with the first place come on
you have to you have to play to win
let's go let's go let's go fishing go
fish
okay let's set this up let's set the
stage let's set the stage to let's not
be careless now okay hang on hang on
hang on calm yourself now okay let's get
this Bishop here you know you want to go
there get to your home happy gilmore
this is your home Knight get to your
home let's do this g5 okay let's take
this one the furthest advance night by
the way I'm gonna go with that one open
up the H file look for made on each - H
- H - H - H - o H - I insist I insist
let's take this guy out uh-oh Oh H - a
lot of pieces are hitting H - let's do
this this and then this and look for f5
next f5 open up that diagonal and the
king is dead Forks and I'm gonna take
here tricky stuff happening discover
checks tricky stuff uh-oh I have this
one resignation resignation back to
tournament 166 141 that guy keeps
winning 203 I have
how much time left 203 okay I have time
to win this one hopefully if I win this
one I think I have it I think I can I
think I can I think I can I think I can
let us see about that I think I can't I
think I can move quickly move quickly
remove the dark square bishop and look
for me remove the dark square bishop and
look for me if they move F now this pawn
is hit I have to watch over my Bishop
though pawn push I react pawned here I
could take and it's in a pen let's take
this out I could take that pot I
probably should have taken that pawn
first Knight two-year get it there get
it there get it there let's come here
otherwise Knight f4 with tempo I was
gonna come here Knight f4 hitting the
Queen so next up what do you want to do
actually display Knight here if it's
taken my LightSquared bishop comes to
life and I want to pivot one of my
pieces here let's support this get pawn
push in here
Queen to f5 hopefully the knight moves
like a grab on g6 route to e1 how much
time do they have how much time is left
in the tournament let's capture away
from the center I'm on the knight I'm on
the knight here and they might move to
f4 that could be strong how much time 55
seconds 23 22 21 that's a past pun that
is a passed pawn I might want to just
take that night push this pawn here look
for me making a couple maybe take this
knight um okay just force that what do
we have I want my knight on f5 Knight n
f5 coming up soon with tempo I'm on the
rook let's just do this even if it's
wrong even if it's wrong I'm doing it
they'll probably take it and play here
next how much time is left I'm gonna do
this just to burn time no time no time
no time how much time is left yes I got
it there it is whoa that was tight that
was very tight right there okay first 40
big crowns that's for granola bars
confetti